but welcome everybody to the data
science hangout
for anyone joining for the first time
this is an open space for the whole data
science community
really to connect and chat about data
science leadership what's going on in
the world of data science and
all the questions that you're facing
so we want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's multiple ways to ask
questions
all the questions are audience-led so
you could jump in live
put questions in the chat
or we also have a slido link that tyler
will share in the chat in just a moment
but with slido you can ask questions
anonymously too
and just a quick note that it will be
recorded and shared up to youtube for
anybody who missed it as well
but i also just want to say thank you so
much to everyone here
for building the data science hangout
with us this year
i can't believe that this is the last
one
for 2021 and
somehow
five months have flown by so quickly
um but i'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today ryan garnett and
brian's a manager of data management
insights and analytics at green shield
canada
and ryan i'd love to just kind of start
things off by having you introduce
yourself and share a bit about your team
and the work you do
totally yeah thank you well first let me
say thank you for for the opportunity
you know
i secretly have been following you along
online like many other people i'm sure
that follow along with a lot of the
great stuff that you're doing and
shout out to everyone here like our our
studio and r as a community itself is
just fantastic and i'm privileged to be
part of that um a little bit about me uh
i'm a bit of a weirdo i'm not your
stereotypical
data sciencey type of person i actually
come from a recreation background so
when i was a kid i wanted to be yogi the
bear i wanted to work in a national park
and do all that kind of stuff so i went
to school for outdoor recreation parks
and tourism and geography that was kind
of my thing in
northwestern ontario show up to lakehead
university uh above duluth for you
americans so real real north even but
above minneapolis
so that's where i really got introduced
to kind of data and analytics and stuff
like that but from the geographic
standpoint of using gis for for those of
you who are are facial people
so that kind of led me down my path and
then i did remote sensing which is using
satellite imagery and i i jumped into
the world
of data and analytics that way not your
data science 2010 2012 kind of like
famously quoted a position and
if i may i think we were doing data
science really early in in the uh the
geospatial world you know big figure not
big but big data like satellite imagery
and analysis and we're doing like a lot
of repeatable kind of things there so
that really led me into it and then
as i went through grad school and stuff
like that i wanted to transition out of
being just a geo type of person and i
wanted to get more into analytics and
and building it that way and going that
approach and that happened when i was at
the city of toronto
i started the data science kind of team
in practice
city of toronto uh it was still early
days 2015 2016 and that's where i was
like okay i got to do this myself like i
need to start taking on those kinds of
personas and characteristics and with
the open data team and that's when i i
started my art journey in
2018 that's when i start to
program and script and
what's a function like all those pieces
so i'm totally not your stereotypical
person i don't come from that computer
science statistics background
commerce or sorry an economist econ kind
of piece but i think as we start seeing
data science evolve from that famous
quote is the sexiest job of the 21st
century you know in that that area we're
starting to see that data science is
migrating a little bit from
a tech discipline that comes out of
engineering computer science like
statistics
into
an objective
approach to solve problems and and
how do you solve problems we need that
domain knowledge and that's where we're
starting to see that real big shift in
companies like our studio because i'm
always going to do a plug because i just
think you guys are awesome i really help
democratizing that so that people can
jump in at different levels right you
don't have to have a phd in machine
learning or data science from stanford
university to start solving these
problems objectively through
a code-based approach and using best
practices or standardizations of things
like it really is being put in the hands
of people and that really excites me
that really excites me so uh rachel as
we spoke before i i can talk a lot so
i'm going to pause
no that that's awesome thank you for the
intro
uh in talking with you a few weeks ago
too i
was
so impressed by the like process your
team has gone through to start to build
up
the analytics environment and i think as
we wait for a few questions to come in
from everyone
that might be great to to touch upon
yeah
thank you for putting me back on track
i'll appreciate you to be my my north
star
um
so i joined green shield and for those
of you who may or may not know green
shield is a healthcare benefit provider
in canada we're actually a
not-for-profit so we're a social
entrepreneur like social kind of company
and we want to improve the health and
life of
the of canadians and we do a lot of
social impacts and that really drew me
to to the organization and it was done
geo so i was like great like like my
whole my whole transformation so i came
in and and we were we were a fresh
upstart kind of team so i joined in
february they had started their team in
2018 kind of time frame and i was
telling you before there's kind of two
approaches that we generally see teams
get built either you build a strong
engineering you harden up your your
infrastructure and you build it out that
that type of approach like really
hardcore sometimes it's a bit of a
theoretical like if you're taking a
bunch of graduate students or phd
students to build up your team or
your how we approached it was we want to
show the value of analytics and an
organization that has stereotypically
not been data and digitally driven like
how how we grew up as an organization
in the healthcare providing space that
wasn't our number one 4k so how do we
show the value to senior executives
board members because we're not for
profit so the approach that was taken
and i can't take any credit for it that
was the previous team like how they
built your team was let's have some
domain experts that are super interested
and let's have them play
i mean that in the positive right way
play with data and start showing because
they know the domain they know things
they're really good with customers and
in our in our other lines of business to
be able to show how data can provide
value
and and that was great so a lot of
things were focused around poc and
really quick and like that iterative
kind of approach like let's show stuff
quickly and then
they caught lightning in a bottle
like they absolutely caught it and it's
like yes we have it
now what do we do with it it's that
common piece like now that i have
lightning like what do i do with this
bottle of lightning and and for those of
you who may be like what is he talking
about like alexander bring up no no no i
mean now that you have interest and you
have your leadership really like there's
something here how do you turn that into
like production how do you scale it how
do you
replicate something that
feels not replicatable and that's that
whole startup and poc kind of
environment so
what we what we did when i joined is
like well let's take that approach and
let's build on it but let's build the
foundation and let's kind of put some of
those pieces in there and and foundation
for from a production standpoint has
quite a few components
and one of the things that i really
wanted to harden up and and still in
because we're we are an organization a
company is like a product line approach
like let's have some products
products can be repeatable so let's
build that kind of culture in there
let's make people's lives easy as
possible
and let's always provide a space for
exploration
where people can try and where they can
play and where you know
we hear the buzzword you kind of fail
fast i'm like well let's explore quick
and then that kind of fell fast without
using the f word that people are so
terrified of like no no let's explore
let's do quick and see if there's
anywhere to go
um as we got in again i'm going to plug
um
we were not a code first kind of
organization that's just not how we were
and that's that's how like the approach
that was set up because the domain
they were really interested in going
there and we had a couple people who um
had dabbled in in our and we're doing
some things and then we have we have
superstar albert uh a software developer
turned data science so go to us turning
people over and he's our superstar and
these are our big time data scientists
so we decided that we would like to have
a stack and and we chose our studio
for a couple reasons uh one so there's
more than one person myself that could
use it so that was always a positive
people were open to it
i think our studio and rs approach um
with using tidy as as that kind of
grouping of packages the tiny verse
allows for a really easy uptake and
swinging people up into like getting
them moving forward and then the
platforms i swear i'm not doing this for
marketing sales but the platform really
allowed us to like build
so as we were
like many organizations not uh data
first like that's not how we started we
didn't start in the internet age we
didn't start in the data science age
working with it we don't have like
here's your amazing 64 gig laptops we're
all working with like our standard
laptops and it kind of minimized some of
the things that we were able to do so
that's where
where i reflect back and like to your
question how do we get going
making things easier so we build like an
infrastructure where people can log in
and do things and share code differently
and change that whole that whole working
approach that you can explore and
collaborate and literally build in time
to educate
right so we have every couple weeks we
do called data ops
trying to
find buzzwords you can say it right like
we're doing that and like introducing
people on how to do things whether
that's like code based stuff and get
or
building apis and building functions and
introducing them to our connect and work
um workbench and things like that so
we're really trying to build that piece
always with the goal of building a
product that serves our use cases
i'm sorry i went way too long no
that's really helpful and i see bruno
just asked a great question around like
understanding the challenges that you
went through too and bruno ed i'd love
to have you jump in and ask that too
sure can um and they really just wanted
your
holiday outfit
give us a shake ring the bells
so how difficult was it to transition to
code-based data science so it's it's
something in the life of an unorganized
organization
uh you you have to get stakeholder to
like believe in what you're pushing so
what was the most challenging part of
that and what kept you motivated so you
said you started i think 2018.
so our team started in 2018. i started
in february 2021.
okay
yeah
so so if i get your your question just
to paraphrase how what were the
challenges and how did we overcome that
transition into a code base and how do
we stay motivated within that piece
yeah
yeah so to just to give a like a context
of where we started tableau and alteryx
were our big kind of like platforms or
tool sets that we use and as we know for
from some of us those aren't really code
code first approaches hence like the
scrappy startup getting stuff done kind
of approach um
how did i do it
i typically
try to break things down into five
questions
and i want to own two
that's all i just want to share stuff
and the five questions in the world or
who what where why when and how
and i want to own the how and the who
everyone else can have anything else
they can have the what they can have the
the why i like to collaborate when with
people but i want to know how i want to
control how we do things
and who gets to do stuff because i think
that's really how you can kind of drive
stuff forward so
that was really a good kind of
transition and in the thought pattern of
getting it in
so
the goal was never like you are now code
everyone
throw your tools away
everything you do has to jump in there
and you better start line by line
pick off the books off your shelf like
that wasn't the approach that that
really wasn't it
at all and from previous experience
doing similar kinds of approaches
i realized
to get people on board and really eager
and willing
i have to take on a lot of those costs
and i don't mean financially like the
cost of building it so
creating really easy to use
use cases
documentations putting on training
pointing people in the direction of
amazing resources which our community
has so much for so thank you you've
really made my my life and journey so
much easier um so that was a really
helpful piece
being open and transparent and
vulnerable myself i think was really um
less
challenging for people because it's not
like oh my gosh this pertinent person is
the world leader in that how can we ever
aspire that's what it's supposed to look
like but no i i i still google how to do
deep player syntax every day
like i still do
um gg plot is amazing but i use a squiz
to to get the code to import it like
like let's be honest like you don't have
to get to the very beginning like the
very end like that the neural piece and
just getting people like go into it like
write it down and use it for yourself
just to document your thoughts and
getting them to transition and like i do
not want you to write efficient code now
i don't if you're trying to write
efficient code today
i'm sorry
you're you're wasting your time
get the proof concept get those kind of
thought patterns and move them along and
really define where certain activities
kind of stop
so for people who are like really
aligned to business and they're rarely
like domain experts
i'm not interested in those people
having to feel that they have to
optimize code to be the most efficient
to run any platform what i want them to
know is solve those problems and then
we'll lift and hand that off to another
group of people who are really
interested in optimization they're
really efficient at that so that people
really understand what their journey can
be and that if they become interested
there is other opportunities elsewhere
so really kind of showing a path of the
force through the trees was that
approach
from how did we get it in
i just made a business case and i don't
oh you just make a business case yeah
well
i chose to talk about those laptops for
a reason so if you add up all the costs
of getting a team four thousand dollar
laptops you have 15 people
you're talking about a really big
machine
like that's a lot of money we're talking
about fifty thousand dollars you can get
and we did get a really big server for
half that cost we have like dual
processor 16 cores terabyte of ram
uh eight or ten terabytes of hard drive
space just to explore and do exploration
on that was financially cheaper than
saying hey
that eight gig laptop that you have that
everyone has
can't store memory so you should really
get them a 64. and that person actually
needs 124 so i would like sixty thousand
dollars in laptops like it just that was
more of a challenge
so we went a different approach and
identified and really did a data-driven
approach like what data sets do people
generally use how big are they what are
the types of questions that people
are currently doing what people want to
do and what can or can we not ask and
some of our like
we don't have the world's largest data
but
we consistently work on 50 gig files and
we're working on multiple of them so we
can't even put them in memory to do a
summary so you can start seeing how when
you when you break the problems down
into like little kinds of chunks we can
build that case to transition over
and in the last piece because i i know i
always talk too much um
is really listening to people like what
can't you do
and i think going into that approach um
you know i like to be the hulk i'm
always angry and i want to control that
anger and use it for good um is
what what is it that you can't do
because most people want to do their job
and they want to provide value and they
want to be really awesome so
that's holding them back from making
that leap in that step so it's like oh
those are your issues let me solve those
with you
and then you just kind of break it
forward and then
lightening in the bottle is now in
another bottle
so i'll pause if you if you have any
other comments or follow-ups or if
anyone wants to build
frank i see you were unmuted i didn't
know if you wanted to jump in and i see
bruno giving a thumbs up
not yet okay you know muted the whole
time rachel okay sorry
amazing here frank i love your beer hey
ryan
just said my name's javier just a quick
question for you um
i find myself
so there's you know hadley has this
principle of three where it's like if
you find yourself copying and pasting a
function or something three times like
why not spend the time to optimize the
code such that it could be three or
three hundred you know iterations of the
thing you're trying to do
yeah we say two in our company
okay
so i find myself getting into these
traps where like
it takes me more time than i had planned
because i'm trying to work out a
function that could then be used for you
know
like future purposes
as opposed to copying something like 10
times like that would be a lot faster
right and just changing the inputs
but
setting it up nicely so that i could use
it i don't know do you have any feedback
on that because i i do sometimes lose
track on like
you know am i spending too much time on
this you know per iteration or whatever
it is you know trying to like finesse
this function
100 and like you're so on point with the
realities of a team and then when you're
up scaling and you're moving and you're
evolving into like that kind of piece
and and we don't talk about that so much
as a community and i'm so glad that you
brought it up because i experienced that
myself so i i'm gonna literally answer
your question i'm just going to preface
it in there giving a little bit of
what's going on that was me like in 2018
like i had i'd worked in like software
companies so i know what's possible i
helped design them and help build them
and put that together
i didn't know how to read in a dang file
alone doing anything else so we have
this this
illusion and image of what code base
should be and that's a really big step
and
typically we educate people to go
linearly right like start here and here
and now you're perfect and and now
you're awesome
with the assumption that everyone can
learn that way and and in your space and
in my space we're were adults right we
were adult edge learners and that's not
how we learned so
going through that and like working with
people in like previous
places
i
put people to school at 60 years old and
got them starting to code like learning
and teaching that kind of stuff so you
see that and they always want to get to
that part
what i've what i've recently done is
kind of break stuff out into like two
kind of areas one was taking something
that i heard at a previous job um the
trl the technology readiness level
i'm only saying that because what it
allowed me to do is take that and break
it down into little tiny segments of
chunks so the trl the technology
readiness level is was built by nasa i
believe to kind of say how mature is an
is a software product so that you know
like how long now you can commercialize
it from working with the government it
was really not awesome for data science
and data analytics so it was missing a
whole bunch of pieces so i kind of like
how does that work for us because we
were building a startup we were building
software and working with the government
and they used that kind of piece and it
really helped me understand your
question
right it's like okay you start at one
and you go to nine and then there's a
bunch of stuff in between
where at what point would you think that
something is like a product a software
product that's working you know it's all
functional based it's calling there's no
hard code kind of stuff well if you
think of that as like seven eight nine
like really far down the line
would we assume that it would start at
one
would you start building that function
at one
point that's a good point
yeah that's a really good way to look at
it right
right so so if you take that kind of
thought like the design build test
sprint kind of thought pattern is like
one from trl literally my napkin and
drawing so we go back to like first your
comp side do your pseudo code it's the
most valuable like okay yeah it's really
valuable but we jump into syntax now we
kind of do it that way so
that's kind of like where i start to
like see like okay yeah even for myself
i need to stop do that doing that but
then also for the team
i
want people to get as close to 100 but
never over 80
because diminishing returns happens in
that 80 to 100 and i'm just using loose
numbers right and that 80 to 100.
so
what value does someone early on in
their stages of their career have
spending multiple extra time to
efficiently do something
than solving new problems so let's take
two roles
someone who's a domain expert and you
pick your domain like you know so much
but
your code optimization programming like
that thing is more lower than the video
game level right you're you're more in
that junior you're not the expert and
then you have the opposite you have uh
someone who's like uh i could code
anything right you give me two sticks
and i'll code it together i couldn't
tell you anything about that business
where do you want to put them
so you want that person to solve the
problem and hand it off and that's how
we've organized our team we've organized
our team to be data science
and then data engineering
and for that reasons like we're gonna
work together into that like five six
seven overlap
so that people are solving problems and
handing them off but there's that
transitionary piece over there for a
couple reasons so that the people who
take code don't mess up but also to
train back
hey we're going to do a code review of
course what are you doing here
oh you're doing that can i show you how
you could do that more optimally next
time
so they're starting to see how that
changes in that education and then
through those experiences
we start seeing how often things are
happening and we start building our own
packages and code bases for our custom
pieces
so that it's like you
i want to use this so i can just put in
a couple variables and it'll do whatever
it is i want it's not coded to a data
set or to a value or a thing like super
efficiently optimal
but by going through the problems and
understanding how often things come up
you really start to understand what you
should build so you're building a bit of
a priority matrix or a priority process
of what you should build and either you
tackle it as your own psychological like
man i'm going to figure this out i'm
going to separate some time to kind of
do it but it's not gonna hinder me from
progressing into like my my job my
project my like solving the problem and
then when i get to a point i'm gonna
work with my my colleagues over here who
are like they're wizards
and they got the the magic wand and they
can bippity boppy boo and just slam oh
it's finished right and then because
it's a shared code based environment
we can look at it and then we put it
into like a knowledge sharing
documentation not in our get like we're
using devops just because we're like
we're a microsoft shop so it's a lot of
those learnings like really investing in
data literacy probably the unsung least
sexiest part of this whole domain is
like really putting it there so that we
can get people
further and further and further up that
ladder and they can make that choice
which if they want to jump ladders
and you know we have a person
i won't say his name because he's not on
here and i hadn't asked but this person
started at zero
really good at sql it's like yeah i can
i can pull some stuff up introduce this
person to r
in a month
doing a bunch of stuff
give him a few pointers
now he's publishing apis
right like you can see that going
through it's like don't try to write a
function i'm going to get mad if you try
to write a function first let's walk
through and see if it gives you the
answer and then let's start reverse
engineering it and like optimizing it
and then tell me let's put it in our
board what utilities we should be
building to be making that happen so
you're not hard coding anymore and then
that's where that learning is starting
to happen and going
but really importantly giving that space
and the opportunity to do it i don't
know if i went too far on a tangent
there for you um if you want to like
streamline me into something that would
be no
this is all also i took a few notes here
so thank you
oh no problem thank you ryan i see jake
that you raised your hand as well for
your question would you want to jump in
can you hear us sorry about that yeah no
worries
uh i had lowered it because you all
started to talk about uh code review
which is what i was um
thinking about i work at the children's
hospital of philadelphia and
we we really encourage code review early
and often and i think that really just
helps build the muscle memory so that
the efficient practices um just become
something that folks do more often like
like we don't want like it to get too
far ahead and then have to refactor a
whole bunch of code because what happens
is folks folks are like too far along
and then get too much feedback and
they're like that's great i don't have
time for it because like they're like
ready to move on with the next step so
instead we start we suggest like start
early and then like keep pairing with
the code reviewer kind of through the
whole process
and uh and i think that's really helped
um like both improve the proficiency on
the team but also reduce like this
technical debt that that kind of grows
if it goes uh too well
if i can add something to that some
other pieces that we find helpful is
like if you're using like an issue board
or any like a sprint session like kanban
we also ask people to identify who they
want to review so that you're paired up
early on when things happen and we've
built a style guide so people know what
it looks like so okay i'm about to start
doing stuff this is kind of our standard
how we look at things and then
um
we put in effort to create a notebook
markdown template so that forces people
to think through the problems and like
put it in together so that they have it
and then it's the starting of a
documentation for that code review and
then they submit it up and then so it's
like okay that that code block
great that's that's actually your
function like you were doing some
exploratory you're doing some stuff now
i know the libraries that you want we
can see all those pieces and and i i
agree with you like code review from day
one and often and then it starts to just
build that muscle memory where people
don't need it need to refer back to it
not so you don't do it but they don't
need to refer back to it to the same
degree
like your your spot andre
and ryan i see there's also an anonymous
question that came in too about this
topic um and it was so without
functional programming how do you manage
the production code base as they grow
get back to you
like from an object oriented if that's
the way that the people if the people
mean that's not necessarily like
what we're doing that would be more in
our it kind of space where they're
building hardcore applications our data
products for us are more functionally
based because our products align with
reports so like building automation on
reports uh dashboards apis and models so
functional really works in there
from an object-oriented space we're not
really
doing that and i don't think that there
is much of an intention to go that
direction
and
the nrit department actually owns that
owns that kind of like application
building so i i wish i could answer but
i would be not doing any justice
i appreciate that though and uh zach i
see you also had a a great question
around domain knowledge versus coding
knowledge and would love to have you
jump in and add that context there
yeah sure so i was just wondering see
this going back a couple minutes now uh
you talked about like you have as you
call them the coding wizards that can do
anything
but of course they then you also have
the domain knowledge
of course like you're gonna have
different people joining at different
points you're gonna have people
as you it sounds like you did you had
the domain knowledge and you went into
the code inside
but you also have then the people that
are creating inside and going actually
i'd like to do something to ed i believe
it's healthcare i'd like to go into
healthcare as my domain focus but um i
already know lots of code i was
wondering
first of all like just a general
question and
uh what do you think is easier to start
with do you think it's easier to teach
some domain knowledge or to teach them
the coding
and then
the second part of the question was
if someone's a coding expert do you make
sure that like they're having
i don't know how often you have meetings
with between teams but do you make sure
like they're working
almost 100 of the time with a domain
knowledge expert to ensure that all the
data's
in the right direction
you've got some really deep questions
there and i love it so so i'm gonna i'm
gonna tackle your first piece and i'm
gonna tackle your second one
from the from the first piece i'm going
to do the classic it depends it totally
depends because the type of person
right so i think we in our in in our if
i can call us
sphere data science sphere like in our
in our sector
either
people pushed it on us or we do it
outside
we think unicorns exist
and everyone's looking for a data
science unicorn and
and i love them
i've met
two in my life but i actually don't
think they exist i think unicorns are
just on my kids tv shows and some of his
stuffed animals upstairs so why i say
that i like to try to be a little bit
funny whether or not i am that's
different is
a unicorn really is someone who has got
all that domain knowledge and all that
technical stuff thrown together and that
technical stuff can be multiple
technical pieces right and then you have
communications if you choose to put it
in there or not so it kind of depends so
why i'm saying that is through some
experience we in previous roles at the
city of toronto like in our open data
team we were trying to hire unicorns who
just want a unicorn factory like it
should just work but if you look at
sports most of the amazing teams don't
have all the best players
you just don't it takes like a whole
kind of well-rounded kind of look at it
so
we
we were striking out on finding some
people and i and it was because
we were looking for a unicorn to do a
role that didn't require it
so there are different personality types
there are people who are like i'm not
interested i'm not interested in any of
that so why would we
like knock them out so
it depends if you are a certain type of
personality that is either one side or
the other that's really if we can just
say like a b really a business i guess
we should say that b could start with
business really be like a business
person and a more technical
i don't think you can really switch it
it'll be a bit of a of a tough haul and
even if you force it on maybe they're
not going to be interested and they
might now in the great migration they
would be a candidate to leave
um from the other standpoint
how can you do it
i think you i think it is
depends on your tech stack and the type
of person so i started to try to learn
code
2003
when i went to college and it was vb
and it just didn't hit me it just didn't
work
and then i tried to do python and then i
tried to do see it just didn't work with
the style so i think it really depends
on the technical piece that it is and
how you learn so that's why i say it
depends
um
sql is what got me into being able to do
things through a code based piece and
believe it or not ms-dos and doing bash
scripts just like line by line kind of
do stuff it got me into that thought
pattern and then with
uh coming into r and the approach of the
tidying like oh you're thinking of it
from a data perspective it wasn't an
easy transition for me so
it depends on what that tech direction
that coding direction is it's going to
be easier or not easier for certain
styles of people
but business is the same thing if you're
not interested in that business and that
domain i don't think you'll ever teach
anybody yet
right like if you're not it um
i think how you need to do it
is make it interesting and analogies to
people like that's has how approaches
that i've done things and then like
i roll back to some stuff that people
have told me over the years like explain
it like you're talking your grandmother
my grandmother's 88 and she has no idea
what any of this is
i was doing gis and my mom and my sister
my grandmother for 100 years said oh
she's doing gps stuff like they don't
get it right so you need to break it in
i think with certain
languages from a tech coding perspective
it's probably a bit easier to teach
elements and levels of that than it is
over domain knowledge because domain
knowledge is experience
and exposure and that's time based
so that would be my long-winded answer
to the first piece and if you can help
me the second one what was that was um
it was about uh
you have those coding experts and
do you enforce them to work with domain
experts more to ensure that the fact
that the data they're looking for
is how it's meant to go rather than go
on a tangent as lots of data people or i
know got a tangent if i'm not
making sure if something's got put me on
focus
yeah
again it depends i would say i don't
like to force anything on anyone and
holding having people hold hands
together can be counterproductive at
certain points so for me
having kind of sprints and team sessions
is really good um the coder doesn't need
to be at the design session
they don't need to be there when they're
talking to the business and trying to
figure out what it is what's the story
but in that build i think it's really
good and this is where we're seeing in
data science
almost a new position the translator the
universal translator between thing is
becoming extremely important
um
but i don't think that they work in
isolation i really do not think that
they work in isolation i think you
understand if that supreme
coder wizard if they have an interest in
learning the business then yeah have
them come in so we hired a person this
year and he's interested in doing that
but let's do baby steps let's get that
person like understanding our business
and how we're doing approaches and then
bring them in with good clients with
good projects so that it's not like oh
my gosh meeting by paralysis so i don't
think it's an absolute requirement
but i think it is good to have
cross-pollination because different
thought patterns
there's diversity there's diversity of
thought and i think that's really good
approach and from a business talking to
the business having that approach like
oh what you're trying to do we can
automate that or we can make it
efficient and having someone who's
literally going to do it brings street
cred to the whole project and the
purpose like if you could get that to me
i can shave three weeks off of this
project so i think there are some
business benefits those domain benefits
of having a coder wizard there but not
all the time i don't think it has to be
like a velcro buddy buddy kind of um
sitting there together if that helps out
yeah that's very good thank you
you're welcome
thank you ryan and isabella i see you
had a question earlier as well and i'd
love to pass the mic over to you
sure
thanks so much my question is also about
collaboration uh specifically around
code review so
often like especially if somebody is
very good at code review like they get
tagged for kind of each and every time
and it stops being kind of the team
activity and
it's like oh that's a code review person
and so i'm just wondering like how do
you prioritize you know making sure well
first of all do you prioritize making
sure that doesn't happen and recognizing
that kind of like additional work that
folks are doing when they're doing code
review and things like that
yeah that's a really hard thing isn't it
okay like
we
we tend to think that superstars should
be available for everything and i'm
gonna approach it maybe a little
different than like than you uh you
phrased it like a superstar that that
coding wizard they're going to be able
to review everything but their time
has a different value prop i'm not
saying their individual hour to hour is
more valuable but their output potential
in that hour is can be so much higher
than than others so how do you use it
efficiently
i think it depends on where you are in
your organization and i don't mean
positionally i mean are you early days
do you have three people or are you a
large team that has a few other things
so if you're early days and you're just
starting
all people on deck like like
unfortunately
you've got to use the people as you have
and
if that superstar that that wizard
has a great personality the learning
opportunity is extremely valuable so so
early on days i think
we it's hard to prioritize but as you
start getting into pieces this is where
i start leaning back and sorry i'm not a
harper of it but that trl how long far
along is your product
like where is it are you starting to get
into like beta release are you starting
to get into like
um
commercialization are you putting it
into operations yeah you probably won't
have a really good set of eyes there
or is it the first time that you've
built something of that nature
like this is your first machine learning
model like yeah you probably want to
have it there so you don't waste a bunch
of time to get it there for the code
like if you would have just told me at
the very beginning
so i think there is a little bit of that
difference so as always classically it
depends
but if i were to summarize it depends on
like if you have a small team i don't
know if you can really prioritize it too
too easily because i've yet to find an
organization like how many uh code
reviewers do you want on your team like
you don't hire just for that right
there's multiple hats so when it's small
we all have to wear a little bit of hats
i think what we do is we prioritize
capabilities in like importance so you
know if i go back to my early days when
i was learning um it's like how do i
bring in more than one csv at the same
time
right like how do i do that how do i
like get that from like a folder
probably shouldn't go talk to the
lead data scientist to figure that out
is there somebody else in there that's
done at one time right like those kinds
of things so i think it really depends
on the level of code in that piece
um
that's kind of where i would look at it
and try in your own kind of thought
pattern to break out the development
cycle into like kind of groups and maybe
not have people jump more than a few
groups at a time
right so if you have four levels of
group is like
first first time thoughts like okay it's
in the poc mvp and product
your lead person probably doesn't need
to code review the design
or maybe they just kind of review the
concept but like if that helps there's
no perfect silver bullet
like to do this unfortunately um
but
i i would say that
some people's capability
productivity has more value than others
so you want to use those times
accordingly
and you know if it's not for production
my mindset goes like i'm sorry it's
lower down in the priority chain
thank you
you're welcome
thank you isabella
and it was just kind of making me think
also like we have this slack channel
internal at our studio where you could
ask questions about
r um and i wonder if like that's helpful
for people too because
you don't have to go like ask that
question over and over again or like
people could see the answers
yeah i think that's really helpful like
our team isn't so much like a an imi
kind of team that's just not who we are
but my previous place i was at we were
absolutely all over slack and there was
a lot of that it's like hey this isn't
working someone just take a peek at it
that's great
i think one of the things i'm sorry i'm
gonna do a plug here like it's not too
much of a slight
we as a
we
society
a
change the way that we respond in forms
and how we respond to questions
right like
if you are a wizard
you're rare
like you're like you are special not
everyone's there so like being able to
write things out so that makes more of
that like iterative kind of step-by-step
process of how you're coding is really
going to help people in the long run and
you as a wizard to not waste as much
time like answering these types of
questions right so if someone's saying
like how do i do a group by
don't put a whole bunch of other non
nonsense in there that's not answering
their specific question because on a
learning curve we're trying to solve a
single problem that's bugging me today
not and this goes back into like some of
the previous questions like how do i not
build something
that's that piece so i think we we can
do a better job documenting answers and
responses so that they're more usable
and iterative to build right so if
someone asks like an answer for one plus
one don't teach them calculus
all right
sorry jake i'm gonna just hop in real
quick it's more of a comment and adding
on to what rachel and brian your
response isn't this really about
getting people or teaching people to ask
better questions and be more thoughtful
in what they ask of the world
absolutely i think there's a mix though
there is a little bit of a mix in that
because there is elitist syndrome right
like there is a piece like i had to
struggle and i started my phd and there
were so many things like hey that's
that's the struggle of the phd i had to
do like okay yeah well then that
mentality we used to do a lot of things
in the world that we don't do anymore
but yeah people need to take some time
to check
you're not the only person who ever
asked this question
in your life i'm sorry there are very
few questions in the world that have
never been thought of right so to your
point yeah we have to ask better
questions i think reproducibility and
this is like the hot buzzword right in
our industry um being able to put that
out so that people can explore into it
is really important but also breaking
things down into the appropriate
response right not to like flex off and
use if we use forms as an example as a
social media post to show how awesome
you are at something
yeah
it's not the place
it's like a library you wouldn't write
in the back of the library on the card
i've read this book in six hours well i
read it in three and a half like i don't
care
i'm reading the book it's gonna take me
six months because i have other things
going on in my life i don't like that so
when those response rates like i don't
i think we can do a better job to get
everyone up we want everyone there
like that's what we want as a community
we want everyone there solving problems
helping and making the world a better
place and if
if the cost of the ticket
to the party is too much we're going to
exclude people
but yeah people have to ask better
i'm
questions
like you do
jake i i saw you had something to add to
this as well about your own team's
process
yeah i think it's a great question like
how do you not overwhelm
um
for your you're more like senior
senior analyst and
i i think that like a second pair of
eyes is always good even if it's a newer
person the newer person maybe just raise
movement through our onboarding and know
some of our standards
that are um
than somebody who's been here a long
time and our standards have changed and
they maybe haven't like upgraded with it
um
so i always think a second pair of eyes
is good even if the code is really
complicated like it kind of helps us
understand if it's annotated well and if
like the variable names are intuitive
like just the second pair of eyes i just
always helps and then you can pass it
off if you get stuck if there's really a
section you're like i'm not sure let me
pass it off to someone who i think is
going to know like now they're using
some prayer functions and you know maybe
uh there's only a small group of folks
that uh on our team who are comfortable
with per um so it's like all right well
maybe i'll pass that section off to them
and then again keeping the the
coder view
um
small so the pull request can be large
but uh the request for code review
should should be like smaller sections
um so that it's easier to review um so
those are just some of the suggestions i
had um from from my team
thanks jake that's awesome thanks jake
um i'd love to
ask a question they might shift gears a
little bit but um
i i mean i realized just talking to
everybody the past few months that
hiring is extremely hard right now
and
i know we talked a little bit about this
too but
building up the
not only the culture but
the way that people externally who don't
understand your company see that data
science environment and like get excited
by it and
i'm just wondering if you're not like
one of the like top tech firms like how
do you do that to get people excited
about
potential opportunities
rachel that is such an awesome question
and i i can imagine
i'm not the only person struggling or
challenged by that right like
we thankfully live in an awesome
sector and time right like for us as
individuals you know
we've got a bit of that golden ticket
but for like building organizations it's
challenging right we know of as you said
those big tech terms of thought the
stuff that goes to it and then location
has a thing right like
canada being in the shadow of the united
states like there's a little bit of that
too right that's the poll
when i joined green shield
i only knew about them because we had
health care coverage for them before so
i was aware of some of the stuff that
they were doing
so some of those other industries
similarly to us
is really lower down and the pre-notions
and preconceptions of what that means
like
insurance or banking or retail like some
of those other sectors that you know you
don't think of startup or silicon valley
or like big day like those kinds of
pieces it's a challenge so how do how do
we do it how have i done it what are
some approaches that we're thinking of
linkedin first off be shameless
take as many people as possible um i
think being a bit edgy and fun knowing
your audience is a bit different rather
than we currently have an opportunity no
like get like
people have so much limited time in
their day they want to know
what you're really going to be like like
what what's it going to be like that's
where we're at today right there's a
plethora of opportunities
um so what are some of the things that
people are really interested in what are
the problems that you're working on like
that's really interesting a lot of
people like to know the tech stack okay
like
am i gonna be working on something i'm
comfortable with i'm no longer
interested in or oh that's new i want to
be involved with it so those are some of
the pieces that that we've used
as an approach um i think being honest
and open is like hey we're trying to
build stuff and you're going to have a
chance to shape it and like organize it
and like put your thumbprint or your
flavor on it those are some really fun
catch pieces to do just for your
traditional kind of like social media
look like networking parts
where we're going
and then i know you and i know where i'm
going with what i'm about to say
where where we're going is actually
making a concerted effort to advertise
and advertise in the sense of giving
back to the community
so putting out our own analytical blog
posts or putting things out on our pubs
putting out media pieces more regularly
to show like
we're doing some fun stuff
yep we are not google and we don't
profess or claim to be but there's only
a couple of those types of places in the
world right so this is the kind of
things that we're looking at and putting
that out more regularly and contributing
to open source
so that people can kind of see ahead of
time and then it pops up on the radar
some of the other things that other
organizations and in my days in
municipal government go there is
changing the titles
so that they just pop up on people's
searches
right like those are some pieces
like yeah you may want to use them that
way and you bake it in but people don't
necessarily read all the requirements
from a search pattern so so those would
be some pieces rachel if we want to
touch and go further i would be more
more than happy
that that's super helpful i i can't wait
to also share that
that snippet with people too
i'm curious from everyone else on the
call too if there's other things that
have worked for you or
even specific challenges that you're
facing right now with hiring
i'm not hiring but as someone that's
looking to get into
we briefly talked about in the chat last
time
i'm 22.
i'm looking to get into data science
sector
and therefore i look at all these jobs
especially on linkedin
where i go
uh i'm gonna be stereotypical at myself
i'm white i'm privileged i went to a
very good school
and therefore i see these job
applications and posts and i go i don't
care i'm going to apply anyway what's
the worst because they're going to say
no
uh
or don't respond probably is why i see
those
but so i just apply anyway but it's
found that and studies have shown that
that hinders a lot of people
uh especially minorities
and
uh people coming from less fortunate
backgrounds and applying
do you think hate generally hr's lack of
knowledge about data science sector
hinders hiring
too much
and how do you think that's gonna that
could be a solution to that
yeah um i got going to this for hours my
sister's in hr so we talk about this all
the time uh generally when i join an
organization some of the first people i
try to make best friends with are the hr
people like that's just my approach
because if you want to get stuff done
you need they need to be your best
friends um
they don't know and they're under the
gun for so many different things hiring
is only generally one element of of the
plethora of hr stuff that goes on so i
would say yeah they're not sure they're
aware of it they are
very aware of the organization they know
how sort of the sector how challenging
it is um
so what i've done for them is
you know what i'm going to take some of
those costs up for you
send me all of them
i don't care if there's 500 applicants
send me every single one of them i will
screen with you
now i'll give you my first view and
we'll put some stuff over and we'll look
at it that way because reading between
the lines is sometimes challenging
right and then also you know yeah like
they can literally see a language or
like keywords searches but within
context it may mean nothing or if it's
like hey i did a human udemy course for
three hours in this that doesn't mean
your screen did
right like so so there's some of those
pieces so i would say they're critically
i think they're critically challenged
um
how how i've gone about it is i've taken
the costs on to do the recruiting myself
i've also
i hope they're not listening um
not necessarily follow some of the
requirements that i'm supposed to i.e
education i personally don't care how
you got there
um because it would be very hypocritical
of myself
i don't i didn't follow that path i
think we live in a world where there
isn't a defined path and people can get
there lots of different ways so
there's a lot of other pieces that we do
to to screen people in and look at it um
one of my favorite teams that that i've
ever worked on was at the city of open
data and for those of you who haven't
watched rudolph the red nosed reindeer
the 1960 stop motion one watch it
afterwards because this comment that i'm
able to say will make more sense we were
the island of misfit toys
we were nowhere close to your
stereotypical superstar team but boy oh
boy did we get a lot of stuff done and
typical hr people wouldn't be able to
find those meshes and nuances of how the
jigsaw puzzle of success would go
together so i think sharing some of
those costs as in like work and
screening is really behooves us as
people who are building teams to work
with hr that way
how would we get there
i think it goes back a bit of your
question earlier that because a tech
person who wants to make a career change
and go into that field and bring that
domain knowledge in but hr is somewhat
like us has some rigid requirements to
be able to get in because there's apps
and laws and other pieces i think it's
going to be a challenge for us
for a decade more
thank you very much
no problem
i see a lot of great comments in the
chat right now i don't stop i see just
raise your hand if you want to jump in
first
yeah if you don't mind um i was just
going to kind of add on to that there's
a whole spectrum of companies zack and
for other people um and it kind of
depends on your bandwidth too like i
think that prior companies i didn't
really have the bandwidth to go through
all the applications primarily because
the company's so large right when it's
like 10 000 plus employees they have
very kind of strict ways with how they
handle applications and
things of that nature
and it was actually quite a struggle
uh because as much as i would try to
explain to the recruiter to filter these
things
there was always a computer that's
always in front that allows some of
these applications to get through
because people are just throwing in a
bunch of keywords and the recruiter then
sees it and then passes it along to you
and i'm like this doesn't mean anything
to me i can't do anything
so um you know my recommendation
especially if you're trying to break in
to the to the area is be very specific
about what it is that you want to do
what area you want to work in and reach
out to those people that you find
interesting on linkedin or whatnot and
just send them a message asking just to
chat with them because a lot of times
you find that there may be a match in
personality or an education and then
that allows you to kind of circumvent
this kind of somewhat broken process
with larger companies um so that just
wanted to kind of put those two cents
out there
that's awesome and then just to add on
to that if there's not a fit with the
person you reach out to generally they
have a network and we always try to help
each other out so we'll point people in
other directions as well so i think it's
always it's a great concept
to just reach out
yeah i'll definitely do that thank you
i'm going to chime in and pile on to
everything said uh
especially at larger companies like a
good strategy is hit me up on linkedin
our recruiting process isn't always as
robust as you you might think it is
yep
mike i i see you had a great point in
the chat as well if you'd love to if
you'd like to jump in and add that
i um
i i'm
starting to think about this kind of
process as well and
we had
at my company we had talked about the
potential for growing
data scientists you know so bringing in
people who
kind of demonstrate the right kind of
enthusiasm the right kind of data focus
and analytical thinking
maybe not necessarily the tech skills
and almost doing an apprenticeship and
saying you know we realize that you
don't know everything yet that's cool
you know but we'll we'll show you how
and you know after a period if you
realize that it's not for you that's
great you know
just
we will we'll send you on your way with
a pat in the back but if you find that
you love it then great carry on
um
and
i wonder whether that's a more
sustainable model than you know
continuing to hunt for the unicorns
yeah
um
i promise i'll be quick i'll and that
and then let others too i think that's
how we're going to see stuff going and
we're looking at doing that very
similarly at uh green shoulder cells do
a little company plug but we're doing
transformations and you're seeing that
and we saw it in other places this
operational model like operating model
and i know not all organizations do that
but the hub and spoke you may have your
core place that is the core but now
starting to put people in other
organizations that are data focused
places know that we need to do this we
need to transition right so putting that
in there and having a strong educational
kind of mentorship piece i think is how
we will grow it
um and just being really realistic on
we're not trying to grow unicorns we're
trying to grow people that can solve
problems that are valuable to our
business
i think it's like if we know going into
that like you're not going to come out
of the unicorn and we don't expect you
to be that then i think that model is
going to work
like superb
and ryan i'd love to just also have you
share the roles that you're hiring for
too and i realized there was a question
that i missed earlier if all the roles
would be for people in canada
um or
so we have a hybrid working model i
think we're canadian only focus i'd have
to check and i'm not sure if that has to
do with like taxation kind of purposes
like i'm not sure we're a canadian
company but we definitely have american
clients like i know that so
i would say apply anyways like if you're
interested we currently have two of our
data engineering piece um
what does that mean it's like your data
pipelines uh building
access points apis they'll always be
working with like analytical kind of
pieces but really shaping up and
building that kind of that whole
practice because it you know
it's missing a lot of organizations so
we're focusing there we have more that
are coming out soon in that true data
science this is where that split is so
for those of you who love that word and
think that's you we won't be asking you
to do data cleaning that's the data
engineering you're going to be focusing
on doing analytics and building models
and then we're going to be looking into
the new year a little bit more is like
that more machine learning engineer so
you as a data scientist can take it to a
certain level and then hand it off into
like a machine learning engineering
person to harden it up so we're really
trying to build things
kind of
i don't want to say siloed but more
focused onto like your skill sets and
your interests and putting it there and
then also i'm a firm believer of putting
in more um
starting out roles like in that analyst
level so people can grow up and i'm
trying to start pushing into like that
data story teller data journalist
product analyst that's doing the
communication and starting to put that
in there
instead of our typical ba business
analyst
so those are some of the things that
we're doing we have a really big
initiative
for analytics in 2022 to 2025 so
keep your eyes on us
you'll see a lot and if you follow me on
linkedin i'm going to bug you because
you're going to see a lot of stuff
coming up
awesome thank you so much ryan and
i know a few people have to
drop because we just went over
the hour mark um so i do want to say
thank you so much to everybody for being
a part of
this community and building the data
science hangout this year this has
really turned into my favorite part of
the week being able to hang out with you
all so thank you and wishing everybody
happy holiday and a happy new year i'm
looking forward to seeing you all back
on on january 6th
i definitely want to stay on and ask a
few other questions if you have a few
more minutes ryan but yeah i totally do
i actually am on a day off so i've got
hours oh
well thank you for joining us on your
day off all right
yeah no i've been looking forward to
this for a long time awesome well
also i shared a feedback form as well in
the chat if anyone wants to take a look
at that and give feedback or suggestions
for next year as well as our speaker
lineup
but um
peter i saw you also put a great
question in the chat when we were
talking about hiring
um
around hiring in the public sector would
you want to jump in there
and peter i could i can read it and if
you want to just add more context feel
free to to jump into
but the question was one issue we have
in the public sector is recruiting when
our hiring process is so slow it makes
us less competitive and drawing in
people actively seeking a position just
interested in any thoughts on that
oh my gosh peter that was five years for
me
at the city of toronto like
creating a role took two years so like i
get it and like
people told me
you got a job filled in six months like
how how were you able to do that so fast
and and i was able to start doing it in
three and they're like how is it work
like how are you doing that and not say
that we did it all the time i had many
jobs that went to like three rounds like
it's extremely slow
so how do we do the competitiveness
one thing that i will put out there i
was lucky city of toronto is a big name
right like we we are a target uh people
we have we have a brand associated to it
so that did help us like i will say that
that was a positive thing that helped us
early on
it was hard it was extremely hard and
and what i learned you know where we
start to get more
qualified applicants if you want to say
it that way more interest from people
that you would not expect
and then just more applicants
was that advertising
like that like what what you're doing
right so
i joined i joined the city of toronto uh
midway through my phd and decided not to
finish and went there and people were
like you're committing suicide what are
you doing you're going to like a large
bureaucracy and like i see it
differently
i see it as an opportunity to make
municipal government like it was in the
60s and 70s where they were doing the
cool stuff where they were doing all the
solving of the problems and i looked as
hey i joined as a manager
as a title and i'm not a title person
but it had a team of like 30 people that
means i have an operating budget how is
that any different than having a grad
program
i didn't have to recruit any grad
students i had people there and i
guaranteed funding i didn't have to
write things so if you take a look at it
a little bit differently and you play
within your rules
and and i kind of throw the rules out in
the middle government peter one thing
that i would say
get to know your um
severance package policy really well
because you'll realize that it takes
them a long time to get you out and in
the public sector delivery trumps
everything
so
what we did is we
asked for forgiveness
and didn't
ask for permission right so
we started to just take over social
media kind of stuff and putting things
out talking about what we specifically
were doing
what it's going to be like to come there
and then we delivered and we delivered
quickly and we didn't deliver perfectly
and there's that has a bit of a purpose
uh one because it it's it's pragmatic
it's impossible to deliver perfectly but
people see things quicker and they see
things often and then they also starts
to dispel this kind of preconceived
conception of like bureaucracy and slow
and boring and things like that and we
started to get out and speak we would go
to events and it didn't have to be me it
could be people on the team and go out
like people will resonate and talk about
stuff and put the word out there and
then joining into the open source
community and like really pushing that
on the inside and doing stuff got people
to be like
oh government's doing some kind of cool
stuff here
like i'm interested in that and then the
thing that we always have
that
uh private sector net doesn't have all
the time is we're doing stuff that helps
society
and there are certain elements of people
who really look for that and really want
to align themselves and we actually had
a ton of people
who were leaving the big five
large tech companies here like i made a
lot of money
but i didn't do a lot of good for what
they were thinking i'm not saying that
they didn't do good but from what they
were saying is i didn't do anything that
was helping what they they envisioned
for values in their societal kind of
lens and what's important to them so
they wanted to transition into that so
by making that just known in your
postings and like the way that you share
it out there and having like advertising
like your social media
presence like this is what we're going
to do and this is what we stand for
that attracts people that allows people
like okay i'm going to go make a
difference and this is how i can see
that i'm going to do it and these are
the things that are going to do it
i'm going to um i'm going to wait it's
going to be worth it
it's totally going to be worth it to
wait and that's okay
um the other shameless thing peter and
i'm i'm already saying this now because
i'm no longer a public employee oh i
stalked people i stopped people my my
buddy uh matt tenny i straight up
stalked him
and like we hired him he was our first
true data scientist at the city of
toronto i stalked him and stalked him
and stalked him
online and pulled him away from like
ezra canada
so
it was something in another municipality
he was looking at other things so if
you're on there matt if you hear this
haha remember those days back in 2017.
um
those are some of the approaches that we
use and
i was okay with it because i knew what
how long it was going to take and how
much it was going to cost me to fire me
so that's what i mean by the sevens
package so like you have some really
good trunk cards that you can play in
public sector
but it's hard
really hard thank you that's very
helpful because i feel like we're really
trying to do something very similar and
develop capacity in-house
uh you know and and do more with our
data uh and i think we are doing some
interesting things and we have some
interesting things on the horizon um but
i've i've just found in you know many
different hiring cycles not just for
data positions but like by the time we
get around to hiring somebody we've lost
half of our interview panel uh because
they found other positions so
um i i like this idea of having you know
because three to six months that is kind
of the window but that's too long for
somebody who is looking for a position
now
and uh so i i appreciate some of the the
strategies that we can kind of wrap
around that
thank you
no problem the other thing that we did
because we weren't able to hire because
of like the talent was just so hard or
waiting for budget cycles to come
through to create new new positions
we did something really bold we took an
entire team who were 55 to 63 years old
and sent them to school for two months
and straight up sent them out so you're
going to school it was york university
so i'll give a plug to them they did a
great job and they were in school for
five days a week to re-educate them and
they went through a whole data science
program kind of piece it was a tough
sell
that means that i i and a few other
people took on those costs of doing some
of the jobs like organizing working with
the business say we're going to be a
little bit of a lull on our delivery but
here's what you're going to get on the
end so that might help you as a
different strategy as well
of um
tooling up if you can't recruit because
the piece because let's let's be honest
side of your desk education is really
hard at the beginning for people i think
that's a great way to top up and improve
when you already have that confidence in
those capabilities those tool sets in
your in your toolbox right you might
have a hammer and a screwdriver but
after a while you start needing other
tools and that's easier when you have
those bases
so i'm not sure if that's something of
interest peter but we found it really
helpful and boy were those individuals
super grateful and they went from low
performance to high performers overnight
and it sparked other people in the in
the team in the organization
organization like i want to do that too
and it just it starts to change the
culture
of like what's acceptable
because output
sells
mubanga i see you have your hand raised
as well and love to turn it over to you
uh thanks rachel i just have a quick
question on uh ryan what o'reilly book
is there on your shelf
what friday oh man
so
do you want to go chronologically
alphabetical or just off the top
i was interested in the one that was on
the far right they were the white
o'reilly book
this one
yes
okay
yeah that's my most recent read
this is how it all began
this is what i use in grad school so if
you're a qualitative geographer this was
really helpful
um
i'll be honest this was over this one
was over my head a lot and then ggplot i
still have to look up the syntax
i read this one on the ttc on the subway
it was just like a long commute
awesome book
it's really well done
super helpful because this is like where
i'm starting to progress now is to
improve access for people so they don't
need to know everything they can just
access through a package and then for my
geo friends it doesn't get any better
than this
thank you ryan you're reminding me that
we talked about maybe having a book club
at some point
um one other question that i see that we
have remaining and if there's any others
that i maybe missed in the chat please
jump in but um bruno i see you had a
great
question on um
well
i won't summarize i'll turn it over to
you
all right ryan i really like
the way you speak how you interpret the
business world how did you develop such
interesting views around business and
people interaction
do you have mentor was it trial and
error but
uh i i believe it or not i don't take
compliments very well so that's really
flattering and hard for me to like uh
digest so thank you so much bruno if i
reflect back
um
trial and tribulation i don't have like
your normal progressional path through
things
i moved around a whole bunch like my
whole life i literally have moved 50
times in my life so it's been forcing me
to have to speak so i think early on if
i think about it that that really did it
another thing for me i had an early on
job where i gave gondol the tours
and i was stuck in a gondola with 50
people and had to talk to them and a lot
of times gondola would get stuck over a
river and we could be there for 20
minutes so it would really force you to
talk um
i would say what truly helped me
uh transition into the speaking is my
love of movies
and trying to break things down into a
movie
i'm very visual but
movies tell a story
and
and people love stories
so if if you can kind of
remove the jargon
for a bet and and i do pick that word
because a lot of business leaders think
like oh here we go jargon they're coming
in with jargon again is is is to remove
that and and be vulnerable and allow
people to be part of your story and
and reward them so telling them and
bringing them involved and helping them
be part of it so so i think following
the script of like some of your favorite
movies or just like how i how i've done
it it's like let's be animated i don't
mind
being silly hence why i'm wearing what
i'm wearing like i have no problem with
it um
if
through my progression is if we keep
going some of the pieces that that go
along is truly being vulnerable and then
then my wife
um she's my sounding board prior prior
to that i had a great friend that i
worked with mike at sanborn and we were
doing geo stuff and we were building
products and he's like i'm a designer i
draw
so i would use him as a sounding board
if mike didn't get it
no one would
so like having those kinds of pieces
so so using my wife like does this make
sense like she's a teacher and she said
she like teaches uh elementary school
school students so nothing in this space
so she's like yeah i get it is this what
it is i'm like okay
changing the approach and then i went
into like analogies so i think having
kind of a dynamic kind of way about
stuff
and
trying to understand your audience and
somewhat into groups and what is really
important for them so some people have
uh true importance on just pure profit
okay like i'm going to use profit kind
of directions of my story some people
are about like no no how's the culture
and the feel and then so you kind of
mitigate and you swing around
a friend of mine told me that i took
offense to it right away and then i was
like oh wait no that's that's not
offensive you're a chameleon right and
it's funny that i bring that up my son
was asking me what's a chameleon i'm
like oh how do i explain that to a
four-year-old like it's a lizard that
changes color within their environment
they adapt and i think that's kind of a
bit of the essence is adapting to your
environment and understanding
what people value and appreciate and
if you can if you can somewhat get there
on a common level ground
people appreciate that because
there are people who want that hardcore
tech and they like every time you speak
it you better be giving me your resume
like there are those individuals there
and they're always going to be at that
level and then there's the far other end
of the spectrum of people's like i'm too
afraid to kind of like ask anything
that's just not who they are
people are somewhere in the middle and
most people you know
nerd
normal distribution like
most people are cut somewhere in the
middle um
we
we get off put right it's like are you
are you seriously
resuming me right now like is that how
we're we're doing this conversation so
kind of breaking it down so that people
can feel like they have something to
contribute and like oh i'm a little bit
higher than i'm like yes great and
they're giving i think doing that and
not feeling like
i'm not saying you are like just one of
the things that i kind of try to do and
i don't do it well all the time is
letting people give more than what you
are you facilitate kind of the dialogue
and let people feel like they're giving
i try to measure
success on literally
finishing like delivering right so my
wife and i are a little bit different
i like the destination less more so than
the journey so if it means changing
around and having people contribute
that's cool that's the journey that's
great for me i love people doing that
piece as long as the destination is kind
of successful so that's kind of a bit of
my mantra i
i care less about how we get there
um but to summarize
being goofy
like if you're okay with being goofy
laughing a whole bunch
trying to tell a story and breaking it
down into like kind of analogies
and
understanding your target audience is
what i did mentorship no i'm still i had
a great person like one individual
but really my mentor has been movies
i just i just love movies
so just using like hey one of the things
i helped out with a friend she was uh
really scared for an interview i'm like
one of the ones that i use all the time
so here's a movie plug
of my approach is eight mile with eminem
right so for those of you who have
watched it you're gonna know what i'm
about to say for those of you don't
uh
fast forward all the way to the last
half an hour of the movie
i try to do everything like mom's
spaghetti the last rap battle i take
away all their ammunition and just kind
of like put it out there at the
beginning right is you just try to own
it and hey yeah you're right i don't
know anything but can we talk about what
we need to do instead so you just remove
all the barriers at the beginning and
just totally be funny about it and if
people aren't laughing it's like great
now i know i don't want to work with you
i love that you referenced eight mile i
said in the chat when we make so we are
making this data science hangout site
where you can see all the recordings and
resources so i might have to add that to
the recommendations
i think i think that's actually a great
point though about ryan's
and
uh
it's really bad that foot speakers from
last week's name
but
yeah it's about like
understanding that we're not perfect and
it's
going yes or no i can't do this now
but you give me the time i'm gonna be
i'm dedicated enough to learn this and i
will get there
and i think that's one of the biggest
skills
uh that
showing that you're vulnerable sharing
you're not perfect
and it comes across like ryan's not
deliberately doing this
but he's saying that he doesn't know
everything and
even oh you can hear my dogs
i love dogs
but yeah it's that vulnerability and
knowing that you're not perfect and
that's came across a lot which has been
really awesome thanks like to be like
openly honest i have a severe case of
inferiority complex
like in this space like absolutely
huge because of my
my history like how i got here right so
so i think owning it is like really
helpful because no one can use it
against you like yeah you're right i
came from wreck
i'm better at leading you on a canoe
trip
than i am at writing apis like i'm
totally better at that but i can also do
that too so do we want to talk about how
we can like
solve our problems for our customers or
our business or our society or like like
just like is that really important if
you want to talk about it like i'll
totally talk about it with you but like
really like you said zach like owning
that like it's really
i think it's what we we should be doing
just society but like i don't think this
is the our studio philosophical soapbox
session
i love that though that's so helpful for
me too
and also we still would love to go on a
canoe trip with y'all
we'll go to canada yeah yeah come on i'd
love to take you on a wilderness could
you trip it's awesome
i know
we're we're quite a bit over two but i i
love this this conversation here and i
unfortunately have to go get ready for
another meeting but
thank you all so much for for jumping in
here at the end too and all this
conversation is awesome
bruno i see you're raising your hand so
i want to make sure that
i didn't miss something you're about to
say oh you're waving okay
yeah these have been these have been
really good i just want to say this
before you end this
i really do appreciate it like i said
like i'm probably the youngest person
basically inexperienced but i'm learning
so much every single time
and yeah
you know learning from us is one of the
best things and
yeah
you're not a bug you're here
yeah
everything you have has got value
yeah don't think of it that way
thank you so much ryan again for rachel
yeah thanks thanks for providing and
allowing me to have this opportunity
it's been awesome i really think this is
awesome uh i was nervous
i totally had butterflies i was nervous
uh you guys are an amazing community so
uh thank you i hope it's been okay
for those of you who would like to
continue i love to chat as you can tell
i will talk all day long so
i look forward to hopefully continuing
this relationship uh with you all in the
future yeah this is great ryan and
that's a question i forgot to ask you
what is the best way to connect with you
is it linkedin
yeah i'm a linkedin twitter kind of
person uh i think i'm a little bit too
old for snapchat i think they have an
age barrier where they just like kick
you off if you sign up hey i'm not on
snapchat either
yeah i know that i get addicted to
videos so i'm staying away from tick
tock but yeah like linkedin and twitter
are to me i'm pretty simple i'm ryan
garnett 78 you can decide if you want to
choose what that number 78 means please
be friendly
and that's who i am
awesome thank you so much ryan have a
great rest of the day everyone and happy
holidays happy new year looking forward
to seeing you in 2022
you